good morning everyone yeah so many
complaints that I've been sleeping I'm
singing so you know what fuck'em sing
everything you say today yes Oh sister
you look so beautiful today keep going
but I have diarrhea
oh no I'm kidding I'm I'm regular you're
right
actually took a probiotic why I just
felt like it I don't know I don't really
know what they do but people are always
telling me like you should take your
probiotics that mom once told me
everyone's telling me to take probiotics
and then someone once told me they owe
it takes just about six months for them
to get you regular right six month wait
you wanna hear something crazy
actually this is crazy when we we like a
while back interviewed like a celebrity
trainer and like at that point I was
like super fat and I was just like all
right do me whatever it like give me the
stuff so he put me on this plan that I
obviously didn't follow the one that
works us out right yeah I just forget
the same but and he was like you tell me
all these things to do in addition to
just like eating healthy whatever and
one of the things was like take this
probiotic I'm like that's something I
can easily do like it doesn't change my
life I'll just take it in the morning
Hoosick but you got to start start off
taking a lot and then you like wean and
then you're like once a day I'm like oh
yeah money he's like 16 - like no 16
pills probiotics like for a week and
then a traumatic sour 16 pills yeah
I know but seriously 16 probiotics yeah
that's when I was like maybe I don't
want to be thin maybe it's not with the
price it's not for me they look just
like so sporty today I know what are you
doing after this I mean I heard it's MLC
is that her yeah Mel B is scary spicy
yeah Mel C sporty spice who came out
with the banner of a lifetime on her
solo career I turned to you like a
flower leaning to bow it's the Sun
people really only refer to Victoria
Beckham as the Spice Girls who like you
know had a career after spice world but
mm-hmm
I totally disagree I would say Mel C
really had the solo query over lifetime
like that
now be equal to that of Justin
Timberlake like then Malby just became
like professional male being
professional famous but not like didn't
have like a career afterwards in terms
of like singer designer like she was
just like person judge on the show yeah
yeah and Dancing with the Stars
contestant former Spice Girl yeah nice
work if you can get it by the way I know
you didn't watch friends from college
but there's this hilarious scene where
they go to Atlantic City and they're all
like wearing wigs for this bachelor
party and they think and they think that
this one girl is everyone in Atlantic
City like all these tourists thinks it's
Victoria back I'm just like wearing
sunglasses and has that type of wig it's
so funny very similar to the time I went
on vacation with my friends to Miami and
everyone thought I was Snooki and I let
them I got into a club when I was like
12 cuz they were like yeah Mike yes it's
me and there's what we came out like I
just saw you on Wendy Williams I guess
was a very good interview it was a very
good year good time well it does feel
like we did the show yesterday probably
because we did but usually it feels like
six years go by before I just had such a
relaxing day yesterday um I watched the
fearless tour journey to fearless I saw
you and snitch you and mrs. hat had a
day I did invite you over and you said
no I invited you to lunch yeah yeah but
I was honestly too tired to go to lunch
and then I you know I come over you
didn't miss anything because lunch it's
like the restaurant refused to make good
food yesterday do you know any mean wow
and I'm subsetting and they even grazin
I even pulled a send it back moment
because I got a wrap and usually they
make it like really crunchy on now time
that's the best part of the wrap and it
came like all like sad and cold and I
couldn't just pop this back in the
panini maker just like make it a little
crispy he said of course comes back with
a glittery colder and less flaky than
the last time and I just shut my mouth
and eat it well I opened my mouth and
ate it that's so sad I didn't know that
but I FaceTime you guys while I ate my
lunch so feels like I was there what was
your lunch
avocado toast super feel oh god yeah
just as I've been feeling like garbage I
feel better
do you want to get lunch after this um
we're working out do you want to come no
what time 1:00 o'clock
no I can't um because I already did my
hair and I have to work today
sweat oh your hair's no it's more I'm
not that person it's more pain I'm not
Margo I don't do a workout and not wash
my hair
it depends on the workout Margo you do
that no you do that you walk
for hours Margeaux he said he didn't
want a microphone and now you're talking
but it's fine because she could just
wear a hat because she's mrs. hat
well whatever no I'm not coming I guess
I'll go and try myself moral of the
story oh okay will you feel you're never
alone when you're with the tick that is
so true you never alone when you're with
Christ or Theo or just the number one
dr. political refugee on Instagram so
actually Marga was with me and she
wasn't being helpful but yesterday I
went to go be you know like almost a
year ago like I journaled for about a
month and I was planning on like turning
into a book I wasn't like journaling my
feelings I'm not a loser
well I was a year someone who would make
fun of you yeah
but it was like journaling like Andy
Cohen Diaries Jerry wasn't totally it
was diary
if you journal like stay away from
Claudia you know I just will ruin him
you know I don't think it's weird to
journal I think it's weird if straight
boys journal sorry and I'm gonna say it
it is weird do either of you journal
back there you used to okay that's the
second time I made that mistake when we
were in Nashville we had like a big crew
and I was like usually when you join oh
I'm journaling
and this guy was like sitting there and
he was like I don't know like once day
I'm like cool bro me too yeah it was
really terrible I need to stop bringing
it up but I did journal and I did it
like in a satirical way you know satiric
satire are you familiar and it was just
like documenting the life of someone who
is like an absolute nobody but sometimes
this is somebody and the dichotomy is
super interesting it was also right
before I launched the first dirty jeans
to our show so um I did it for about a
month that's like a test and it would be
like a sample chapter that I could like
send to people um and I just went back
and reread it and I just have to say
like I'm hysterical and like I think I'm
a writer and I think I'm gonna start
doing it again that's so exciting
because I just think now that was like
okay now eight months later you know you
shouldn't or what you should do is like
this was a month and then you break for
like a full year yeah this is what
happened when you're nobody in one year
yeah when you're nobody and then
overnight like people want to talk [ __ ]
about you even though nobody knew about
you to begin with but now everyone's
talking about you and only in a negative
way even though the people who are
reading about you didn't even know who
you were in the first place right so the
last day i journaled was february 27th
for obvious reasons i said i got an
agent exhale Yeah right so I think it'll
be interesting that only to like see the
arc of someone who goes viral and a
negative way but also like a new
comedian February I was prepping
my show Caroline's 200 people next
February got an offer to do you know I
don't want to say cuz like it's a
surprise but like it's a big deal oh is
it the surprise that I know yeah that
has to do with um I don't know what very
cool we have a great show for you today
because we obviously have the
fascinating stories that you before
sorry the past I saw that you should
know this morning we've been updated to
our basket if you're new here we keep
baskets around just to make us feel good
and we love a good arts and crafts
project and this basket in particular
just like remember some of our heroes
right keep them in our hearts and our
minds at our sauce so this is a basket
of people who we think are misunderstood
you know we think they need justice for
a multitude of reasons like we grew up
thinking that Sharpay Evans was this
real evil monster when in reality she
was just a true talent who cared a lot
about her musical theater right
Department if she's one [ __ ] Lobster
and ported from Maine that's so hard
right now is the for cousin's lobster
Tartine also Lilly Moscovitz from
Princess Diaries is in here because she
was actually just a good friend and like
made out to be a weenie and also she was
an original influencer with a web show
and like we respect fellow influencers
Meredith Blake was just trying to you
know get her [ __ ] together marry a rich
man and these two evil twins came in and
really ruined her life and really don't
get us started on Gus John but as of
yesterday we've decided to make a new
addition to the basket because Jackie
has made his discovery of one Taylor
Townsend who was in a character from The
OC if you're not familiar feel free to
catch up she was made out to be like
this evil villain was always coming from
a resin she was like this goodie - she
was annoying [ __ ] but Jackie offered a
you know a different theory and and it's
interesting I think you should listen
Jackie it's an interesting you have that
well interesting because when first
Taylor Townsend came on she was meant to
be the evil villain like she's sleeping
with Dean Hess they're getting worse -
kicked out of school then I guess like
Mischa Barton went to the producers and
was like I'm not doing the show anymore
so then the producers had she no rethink
things and start to use characters that
they were already paying to complete the
storyline into season four so Taylor
Townsend has a turnaround moment and you
know he took a lot of her doing good
things for her to be on my good side
again like she really was like a an evil
conniving [ __ ] and she had to make good
and she really really did and then in
season 4 like watching it you would
think that they put her and Ryan
together just because like they were the
last two blonde people I know she really
is like the best person Ryan could
in with like she had her [ __ ] together
she's so funny she's so smart she's like
try [ __ ] lingual and not even like oh
uh hey I'm oh you it's like she speaks
fluently sorry
can you just give me a brief translation
what do you take a day like oh yeah I
speak Spanish right bank open city
yourself like technically like a
traveler you probably do but do you
think you speak better Hebrew better
Spanish Spanish really I think I speak
better Hebrew Spanish comes to my mind
first Hebrew I have to go like sometimes
I do both like I do a sentence with
heavy burger have Spanish I mean we
should start our own country have a brew
have Spanish totally wear calorie still
exist in the way that I think I'm
trilingual even though I speak like
quarter Spanish and a quarter Hebrew she
was fluent and she's only 17 out of high
school right you know so while the
president was OD'ing and Tijuana like
you know she was hitting rosetta stone
and I just think that's not I think that
something has something that we should
take like maybe she was using Skillshare
maybe she was using Skillshare to new to
take online classes to take online
classes more than what the harbor
curriculum had to offer to learn new
skills new languages and so that she
really would like if well honestly we
could all learn a little something from
Taylor Townsend I think that's what
you're trying to say we can all learn a
little something from Taylor Townsend
and if she taught us anything it's that
you know you're only as smart as you
know yourself as the limits that you put
on yourself
and if you want to learn more and
inspired if you want to learn more in
life like there are so many ways to do
it and Skillshare is one of those ways
Claudia thank you for sharing happily
there are classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing for your journaling ah oh my god
you could take your journaling to the
next level oh okay I'll sign up or even
illustration and also we're signing up
mrs. hat snitch over there and if you
don't know the inside joke mrs. hat the
commenters will be sure to fill you in
because it's the best thing that ever
happened on the toast loci it really is
and you know there might be some mrs.
hat updates tonight is all I'm going to
say that's all - a join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with Taylor Thompson with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free
that's right Skillshare is offering
morning toast listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free to sign up go to Skillshare
comm slash morning toast again go to
Skillshare comm slash morning toasts to
start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash morning toast
suite that Skillshare i just want to
make sure skill share share your skills
okay well that's what i do every morning
here in the morning toast well thank you
for that powerpoint presentation
honestly this basket we have many
baskets in our time on the air we've had
basket of people who need justice basket
of people we take umbrage with basket of
people whose financial situations
concern us and honestly was just the
biermann's
but this one of like misunderstood movie
and TV characters i believe is my
favorite it's so important and like it's
just really like a telltale sign it's
just proof that you can you grow up and
they can think you know stuff and then
you are an adult and like you knew
nothing back then right and i would you
know before any movie or like if you
wanted to write a Broadway show about
the origin stories of any of these
people like you honestly i think the
most interesting origin like prequel
would be the shar-pei one really i think
would be gaston yeah honestly Charvet
kind of to get her justice because then
she got a spin-off called sharpies
fabulous adventure oh right they were so
fabulous and adventurous and she finally
got those lobsters imported from me i'm
gonna relax and renew you go do okay now
are you ready to hear the fat side
stories that you should know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast hopefully it's an avocado
toast a superfood and i should instead
of need because you know it wasn't that
heavy what are other superfoods I want
to know if I've literally ever berries
nope dark chocolate okay okay I mean wow
am I am i healthy I eat superfoods I
don't know like what categorically are
superfoods I just any time I'm feeling
like weak and small and frail I get an
avocado toast because I feel like it has
everything that it needs to give me some
sort of energy like avocados really give
you so much what kind of bread whatever
the hey sweet over the post mates
preferred you can see my phone I want to
see if I'm like looking fat in these
pants I'm no you look I'm guy usually
wear just like black pants but like now
these have like a little you throw they
said like a little
on them and I'm just like so concerned
about my well-being apparently acai Oh a
chi yeah I'm familiar I'm familiar with
their work
yeah sort of and blueberries are
disgusting Jackie I couldn't agree more
and like blueberry flavored is the best
blueberry pie is [ __ ] heaven I just
like the blueberry muffin it's the best
kind of muffin yeah a blueberry yogurt
loves blueberry oh but a blueberry is a
little piece of mush and it's disgusting
it's it's really just the worst fruit
and all fruit is bad okay these pets are
interesting I'm seeing they're they're
okay I don't know if I'm in love but
it's fine
no you look good they're just ants from
revolve his top job I buy I bought
another huge order from her Bob last
night I can't be tamed oh my god she
can't be stopped
yeah no I'm like not to be able to pay
my taxes but it's fine it's fine you
look good doing it yeah I don't know how
to pay my check to the IRS I also like
me to stop talking about taxes and like
my inability till I figure it out
because I'm putting a target on my back
you are but then also we just started
working with TurboTax with TurboTax and
honestly I think this is the most useful
these are the skills that they should be
teaching you in high school in total
you're learning them on the morning
toast so they have a thing called
TurboTax live and it's like a new energy
or taxes it combines the tech with
on-demand tax professionals who can
answer your questions and offer
personalized advice like you know my
[ __ ] ass is breaking up in the middle
than I think he like did I fill out in
1989 also what is it 1989 and I just had
my tour and I hit up my friend Lea
TurboTax Online assistant and he hooks
me up and honestly they're about to ban
me because I've literally asked so many
questions you can get real CPAs and EA's
to help you with your return and find
all the deductions that apply to you so
you can rest assured and stop wake up in
the middle of the night like me then
you're doing your taxes right you've got
real tax questions so TurboTax life has
real tax professional so you can answer
them for you
they have CPAs and EA's who are on
demand ready to give you advice and
answer questions as you go they're tax
professionals get to know you so they
can offer personalized questions and
find all the Junction's that you deserve
whether you're stuck on a specific
question or need guidance working
throughout your turn their tax experts
can give you the confidence to ensure
your return is done right TurboTax live
with CPAs and EAS on demand see details
at TurboTax calm
honest is the most important work that
we do I think of all the brands that
sponsor our show like I don't want to
end up and like I might accidentally end
up in jail one day just cause like I
forgot to pay taxes you know right but
now the TurboTax loss no or like I just
learned
right off is and for the longest time I
thought it was so stupid no it's so
important it's so important it's like if
you are in a place where you might get
into a lower tax bracket right right so
I think the goal is liked by people like
rich people are like oh I donated for
time that's different yeah yeah only you
right I know right stop and you don't
pay tax on us but then if you donate
like millions of dollars and you could
take your income down but then you also
lose millions of dollars but but then
it's all going to a good thing I don't
know it makes you think the government's
making you think
yeah a tricky one then the government
has always been making me do stuff you
know and I'm not down they say I'd
rather give that money to charity than
government totally so so some system you
know Heupel oh I can get a bonus you
know that's what happens yes the hoi
polloi I wanna get into headbands they
give you a headache I know and I just
because I want to go to headbands
I really want to get into excedrin as
well use code talk know it's we had a
code for excedrin like no I get free
excedrin I gotta hook up
I got a hook up really yeah I just
bought it I actually never owned it
section until you gave me some of the
other day it actually helped so now I
have it so here's the thing it works
really well but if you start using it a
lot like your body becomes immune to it
and I use it in like desperate times and
it has caffeine and it's what keep you
up okay good okay I think we're ready
now I feel like we're all we've said
wasted yeah enough to approximately 18
minutes Meghan and Kate's Feud ends
after Prince Charles put his foot down
plus Meghan Markel and Kate Middleton
may have finally come to a truce after
months of feuding following a stir and
telling off from Prince Charles
according to a royal report royal axe
hurt sorry
and when they say where I'll report they
mean Melanie Bradley right or just
someone with a British accent the where
the warring duchesses whose relationship
has been under intense strain following
a number of reported standoffs
will have put their differences aside
after their father-in-law's intervention
it is claimed Charles 70 is bound to
have knocked heads together as the
family spent Christmas together in a bid
to bring the Royals together according
to princess diana biographer Robert
Hobson okay like I don't know according
to precise Diana this is videographer
princess Anna's personal yeah that's the
best line from Morning Glory
and Keaton is on this like low-level
morning show where they can't get anyone
but then she goes as to they're about to
go to commercial stay tuned because
we'll be back with Celine Dion's
personal chef that's really why me and
Jackie fell in love with morning shows
he's told Australia's sunrise show this
week that there was truth behind the
reported spat between Meghan and Kate
who did mr. Dobson oh please I thought
Prince Charles did now that's a source
right I mean we haven't heard much about
the feud and at some point like it has
to come to it but feels like this don't
end do any mean this like Mariah verse
JLo like diva on diva things like this
just don't end but also it's like if it
were to end I don't think it's Prince
Charles who's cracking skulls like yeah
they want to abdicate him its Queenie
vibes if anyone can do it she can no
she's the only person who could really
interfere and be like [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together but when it comes to the
rails there's so many forces aka fake
sources that I had to explain because
forces is also a word that I just don't
believe it literally anything I read
when it comes to the Royal like I'm less
Priyanka Chopra is telling me I don't
believe it
yeah I wear the crown right I mean I've
said it and I'll say it again I'm
patient I will wait six years until this
is played out creaking a fuse is this a
story Taylor and the Kardashians because
if not I want to talk about it first
okay so there's a lot of going on when
it comes to Taylor's but further
personal mm-hmm first the Kardashian
yeah first things are moving the
tectonic plates are shifting okay first
Kim on watch happens I've said over it
with the trailer she'll be in an
elevator with her yes she was like
whatever he's had a break had to cut the
lights man Drake break and what's cut
the lights I'm not understanding are you
okay this song we need he's like cut the
and he drove down the driveway to Kim's
house and cut the lights oh I don't know
that song but I do know what you're
referring to
and it was Kiki of course do you love me
so first Kim's head over H went like
this with her drink she was like over it
then I was like okay interesting she's
over it is Taylor then some interesting
things started happening I don't want to
say that this is a direct correlation
but Kim for k'kaw booty released just a
red lip it's like a red lip liner it's
one color and it's very Taylor not that
she owns red lipstick
but it is crimson colored painting on my
lips if a man talk [ __ ] Danna om nothing
it's just like her thing but Kim is it
is a beauty mobile and red lips are a
part of beauty so I didn't think Ali's
hangout today yes I didn't think
anything of it until yesterday Kylie for
Kylie cosmetics released the balanced on
Valentine's Day collection with a photo
on her Instagram that a picture of three
lipsticks one of them was called forever
and always said forever in no ways yeah
well our story of us story of us that is
[ __ ] I used to think one day I'd tell
the story of us how we met and the
sparks flew instantly and then the other
one was called something else that
wasn't relevant there was a mrs. hatten
yes but it was something Taylor would
definitely say but hasn't said in the
song yet but the other two are Taylor
Swift songs now only songs iconic
[ __ ] songs and that was when I was
like holy [ __ ] something's happening
then I did read a report that Taylor
Swift is now with Republic Records she
had this big member it was a whole thing
you're talking about in her where's she
gonna go she's gonna her music ladi da
she now is with why can't I remember
public records which apparently owns the
E Network and the e Network airs Keeping
Up with the Kardashians and apparently a
bigwig executive up there told the girls
to cut it out so I don't really know how
it's all related I don't know what's
true what's not true all I know it's
that the name of those lipsticks was
[ __ ] weird but I'm still [ __ ] here
for it that's all I'm saying forever and
always isn't isn't weird story of us is
a little weird I don't know I don't
think there's that and the red lip LME
or the red lip is a stretch it's a
stretch yeah so I'm not convinced yet as
if someone who's like not that are you
convinced that something's happening I'm
convincing no not that something's
happening like on purpose if someone's
making something happen but all of these
things are maybe sweetening Taylor up
but I think Taylor like she's the one
who needs to pop be it she's the one who
needs to forget like I'm sure Kimmy and
the Kardashians are fine because they
didn't suffer at all she literally her
whole life was her and she took a year
off like right but it's almost like
everything happens for a reason and
Taylor ended up going on the biggest
tour of her career for sure she made LED
lemonade out of lemons but you think she
would rather have just continue doing
what she was doing I'm a changes he-man
in the words of Kim Kardashian she feels
as if it was meant to happen to her I
had a Paris robbery I don't think that
this is that just just some food for
thought okay I don't but I want food to
eat not the thing I know same he's
starving
next story Teresa Giudice Joe and I will
quote go our separate ways if he's
deported to Italy
oh you mean Claudia said it on the toast
literally two weeks ago I mean
everyone's been saying this but for her
to say it
that's where did she apparently say it
Teresa Giudice has opened up about the
future of her relationship with husband
Joe Giudice enews has confirmed that
earlier this month Teresa discussed her
marriage to Joe on this Real Housewives
of New Jersey season nine reunion cake
Oh literally what I said a source tells
enews that Teresa told her Housewives
co-stars at the taping out of Joe were
to be deported to Italy they would quote
go our separate ways
back in October a pennsylvania
immigration court judge ruled joe to be
deported to his native Italy after his
release from prison Joe was said to be
released from prison in March to 2019
and is then expected to be transferred
into IC e custody that was like such a
random thing for that Judge to do like
it's obvious that he's like friends at
the Manzo's you know Oh totally he just
like took dina manzo side and all this
but that she's never strayed from joe i
feel like this like leakage it's just to
prepare us for what's going to happen
because like right now as a society we
are not prepared it's recent chess play
but you think my tip was right your tip
said that she admitted she had a
boyfriend
no on the reunion she told the ladies
that she and Joe are divorcing and she
is seeing someone else
right this isn't this was 50% but this
might be preparing us for that right
because as it right now we wouldn't have
been prepared and I feel like her people
are like it's fine if you want to do
this but you've been like been so
gung-ho like you're sticking with Joe
you know I'm a boyfriend and you guys
are gonna be together you're gonna be a
family you're not spending off your
family that you have to just sort of
prepare people for so it's coming right
well I always found it really
interesting when things get leaked Amit
from the reunion because I read Andy's
books and for a while they had a really
big problem we're like [ __ ] could not
stop getting leaks like everyone knew
everything and then they would turn off
the audio for the in the hair and makeup
green rooms because it used to be like
when the hair and makeup people were
just sitting around they would watch the
stream they turn the audio off
in the green rooms and they had like 50
like a hundred percent less leak so I do
wonder who leaked this unless it was on
purpose I'm feeling it sound purposely
that lawyer of hers was like you have to
you know compare this cushion the blow
preparedness is key it is okay next
story a little morning show drama love
it hate it hate it
Michael Strahan says he hasn't spoken to
former co-host Kelly Ripa quote in a
long time I wouldn't either nearly three
years after Michael Strahan is
controversial decision to leave live
with Kelly and Michael felt
controversial for GMA the former Giants
defensive end still isn't speaking to
his former co-host Kelly Ripa because
she's a nut job in a new interview with
Time magazine for its February 4th issue
Strahan reveals that he and Ripa are no
longer in touch despite four years of
working together quote I haven't spoken
to her in a long time Strahan told time
I learned through all that went down
with that you can't convince people to
like you
mhm a rep trip I did not immediately
respond to people's requests are coming
okay what explain to me why they say his
controversial decision to leave a job
for a better job like you got promoted
Congrats yeah I don't know and I don't
think this is controversial I think
Kelly like literally I like Kelly Ripa
because her husband is in riverdale
she's friends with Andy she's like a
cute little fella more enjoys her money
but that whole situation was so [ __ ]
up and she handled it so poorly like I
will never forget it she didn't show up
to work for a week when she makes 21
million dollars a year are you [ __ ]
kidding me
because your co-worker quit because he
got a better job and he don't want to be
your side piece anymore but the show
it's the Kelly show whoever sits next
her it really doesn't [ __ ] matter so
sorry
yeah oh my god that really pissed me off
that whole thing she was still out of
control she really was so diva and like
so out of control and she wouldn't just
be happy for her friend no I would just
be happy for what she has right no no
she it's like only industry insiders
bigwigs can even tell the difference
between that morning show and GMA us
peep plebeians it's all the same anyway
prestigious as hell I'll see you good to
go on later so you get to sleep in a
little bit no but she but she did just
that like she was Live with Regis and
Kelly it was really reaches his show and
he had a different women every time
Kathy Griffin was on it and she turned
it into her own show and good for her
and then she had men and some who
[ __ ] cares he did what she did she
took the better job yeah anyone would do
that and like it's it's showbiz no one's
always like
talk to your old co-workers oh my god I
don't have any but if I did no actually
technically you do who I don't know you
used to work places oh that's true
no like I barely talked to them on right
there they didn't know me and I
certainly didn't know them yeah I was
watching some like weird TED talk about
how like TED talks are out of people
isn't a TED talk but it was a TED talk
vibe you know
mm-hm Teddy vibes and like I had the
microphone around the ear yeah and it
was like a powerful motivational speaker
and it came across my facebook feed and
I was in the mood to be inspired so I
opened it and he started firstly talking
our relationships in love and how you
build up to love you don't just wake up
and love someone but it's all these
little things that you know make you one
day just be like oh my gosh I love this
person I was like wow that's cool it's
okay let's go you know I'm getting
married I could use this and then he
starts relating it to his larger point
that that's how it should be in the
workplace that that's how you get people
to love their job and that the job and
the workplace should be like a family
and instead of being coworkers we should
be brothers and sisters so unrealistic
unrealistic and just unnecessary who
looks like one to be brothers and
sisters with your coworkers I have
brothers and sisters brothers and
sisters brothers and sisters but when
your sisters are your coworkers it's a
family affair oh the cameras come in out
for a public affair what was actually I
decided I'm gonna sing and I just
haven't stopped when I was a kid and
that song was the jam of the [ __ ]
century I thought the words were all the
cameras coming for a public buffet and I
was really upset when I found out that
it wasn't cuz I loved a buffet more than
anyone I really do love a buffet like
would you rather have a 5-star seated
dinner or a five-star like classy not
like golden nugget nugget like real
buffet like I flip a card yeah I think
buffet I like both bags I do like a
little bit I'm in a little bit of
everything type of person except
sometimes with a buffet you know you
might get the last batch of fries right
and that's the problem a cold fries the
problem I have with the faces like the
exercise of it all like having to get up
every time you want more food instead of
just like demanding someone else get it
for you yeah I what about like a buffet
with waiters mmm that sounds good you
should without for your wedding the
point I mean I wanted to do a buffet for
my wedding but then I was told like
that's not done apparently like it's
tacky but now that I think back like
every buffet wedding I've ever been to
is so much more relaxed and so much more
fun no and it's
like my theory when it comes to food at
weddings it's like you're either there
to hit the dance floor don't bother me
with food I'm not eating like I'm here
to party just shove like a dinner roll
in your face every couple hours just so
you don't die right and so that person
is the one person the other person is
like there to eat I've been at weddings
where I show up hungry and uh oh what's
the next course whatsoever so it's a
vegetarian option oh really you're gonna
hit me with a risotto I want a [ __ ]
dragon so you've been into a wedding
with them Ben is just like he nobody's
like this short bit rib is not up to par
to like send it back at a [ __ ]
wedding that is so money so I feel like
buffet solves the problem both people
can do their thing you know the hungry
person can have as much as they want and
the damned uh you know the party drinker
person doesn't ever have to sit down bro
I agree so I was team buffet I was
overruled
whatever hopefully you guys can have it
and I can come and be a guest out of
buffet style wedding I just want to go
to a buffet by the way we haven't heard
back from the country club chef follow
up I don't know I don't want to like you
know like ruffle any feathers so oh by
the way we forgot to mention me if Ryan
heard on the show today he'll be coming
in like 10 minutes
yeah after we get through these last few
stories a little bit of business side
business news sis's it's a season is new
sort of business I think when that helps
sweet hearts candy hearts you know them
oh yeah Josh are not available this
Valentine's Day for the first time in
153 years wait I just got some if you've
been looking forward to it there must be
old if you work did you say you like the
brand there's a bunch of brands who make
them if you're if you've been looking
forward to exchanging the classic candy
conversation hearts with your loved ones
on this Valentine's Day you're gonna
have to wait another year for the first
time since they made their debut in 1866
the New England confectionery company
Necco that's what that stands for will
not be selling sweet hearts conversation
hearts last July neco closed its doors
and the sweet hearts brand was sold to
Spangler candy company according to
Better Homes and Gardens since it
typically took neck owned 11 months to
produce eight billion candy hearts there
was not enough lead time for the new
company create the hearts and sell for
this season on the bright side Spangler
CEO says the hearts will be available
again in 2020 already giving us
something to look forward to next year
2020 sounds like ten years away it only
sounds like the future like that's where
Phil was from you know yeah Phil of the
future for 2020 but so are you saying
that just this particular brand if you
like there's a bunch of knock
Brants cuz someone I literally just got
a PR package that had them in there
there's knockoff brands but this is like
the Hallmark brand but if you wanted to
just get some you probably could at
Duane Reade yeah yeah I'm sure you could
find like they're you know delish brand
flavor right yeah or nice that's what
like the Walgreens brand is called on
its [ __ ] truck I mean I think it's
this is sad like you guys should have
got your [ __ ] together I mean if you
couldn't make billion four billion we're
billion with spice no I think that's
just like lazy honestly I agree maybe
they wanted to perfect the formula
figure out how to make them taste less
like chalk maybe but it's good it's like
a tongue that's cute
oh by the way I know where I got the oh
wait yes wait I know where I got that um
the PR package it was with my excedrin
my gas-x my tums I get like a an
over-the-counter medication PR package
like once every month and they sent a
Valentine's Day themed one so like I
guess you don't have gas on Valentine's
Day and they gave like little chalky
hearts that is so cute and good tell
books that I ate in 45 seconds maybe
they were was it dark chocolates no milk
milk better so delicious better and I
left them like on my counter underneath
this light and I got like a little
melted and honestly like it was [ __ ]
crack that is so delicious yeah and then
I had a filet mignon for dinner and
Myanmar go watch me score fit down in a
murderous ate of my house
Margot's e in my house from xi meat 11
lunch and she left at 9 it was the
greatest day what did you eat
she got a burger we were ordered from
wolf Atlanta Steakhouse kosher and I got
a filet mignon with herb crusted pan
rice and it was [ __ ] amazing like I
love wolf and lamb but it's a $50 steak
I'm like I just can't if I could do it
every night like I would but I just I
can't spend $75 but the delivery I'm
dinner just for me
you know no no I mean I have and it
probably will mature but I can't every
night it's a treat I mean it's so good I
feel like it's like not that fattening
like it's a steak fattening I don't know
um no it depends what diet you're on but
it is you know red meat ok I had like a
somewhat like a flaming young it's not
big like a flaming young and brown rice
and a fresca I think that's good it's
fine you can't eat it every night
because of what I mean
Oh cuz the bread needs the cholesterol
of it all and we do have high
cholesterol
we're predisposed yeah but I think like
right now I'm low cholesterol I gotta
eat some Cheerios it takes your
cholesterol down that's what they told
me
interesting what else haven't gotten too
checked like can you ever cholesterol be
high if it never gets checked no no
vision final story Magic Mike is heading
to Broadway
enough with this did you know about this
I'm sure I don't know you know what I
might have known but I put it in the
basket in my brain of things I couldn't
give less of a [ __ ] about well now you
do the Broadway bound Magic Mike the
musical will be in teasing Boston office
audiences November 30th producers
including the film's Channing Tatum and
Steven Soderbergh announced today quote
I couldn't be more excited about the
next chapter in the Magic Mike story
so get ready Boston previews of what
disk being described as a musical
prequel to the film will begin at
Boston's Emerson Colonial Theatre on
Saturday November 30th with the official
opening set for Sunday December 15th
so what's out of college I'm [ __ ] and
it said boss Stannis out on Broadway no
but then it from buck from Boston it's
coming to Broadway
honestly the Broadway has fallen so far
I feel like forever like Broadway was
like this pinnacle of originality and
creative new ideas and now every [ __ ]
play School of Rock Mathilda it's like a
revamp Magic Mike Cinderella a frozen a
spongebob Connard Harry Potter you know
I heard Harry Potter is [ __ ] amazing
it's but it's like seven hours yeah dad
wants to go but I just can't say like I
didn't kind of sit for that long but
like I need to make sure though is that
Kazak is that good nerd for harry potter
is he yeah oh they should go it's a it's
a hold it like you would go home and
change in the middle yeah you go to like
lunch yeah okay let's get some tickets
and then we can like get seven hours for
ourselves which we didn't hang out with
you I just like everything I brought
right now is a remake and it's just like
let's be cool and do something new
that's why I'm jarem enhancing was so
good because hey it was around during a
time where like the biggest shows were
like Mathilde school of rock just like
other like revamps of popular movies or
books and it was also just amazing and
been pod is fantastic right also why it
was so good and I really should have
stuck to that and not tried to head till
the silver screen in ruined Mary Poppins
a perfectly good family movie destroyed
by him and the towel attack that he is
um actually that's not true he's
actually very talented but just like not
movies and I think that's fair like I'm
very talented at singing like and comedy
also but that's just rare that someone
that's a dual threat III need not you
know venture into welding because I'm
not good at that you know you don't
try me that's what he thought a comic
does not a blacksmith make no you know
I'm saying you're multi-talented you are
so smart and like well-versed and you
use your vocabulary words but you know
singing is not your thing you know
no I think it's better that it's my
thing come maybe I should work at it hit
it I can no no God this song here that
dream I'm dreaming but there's a voice
inside my head saying you'll never reach
it we have an actual singer coming so
he's listening like he's like - where
did you bring me he's out the door
okay so we have reinhard country singer
on the show we're gonna take a quick
break and go grab him in the meantime
grab a snack take a pass do what you got
to do bring me a snack if you're getting
one head over to our Instagram we have a
picture of Ryan on that leave a comment
if you want us to ask or you can leave a
comment on the YouTube stream we will be
monitoring we'll see you in a couple
minutes don't go anywhere
we are back and I heard a rumor that
Ryan that he's gonna be on the toast
welcome Ryan heard we're very excited
for you to be here give it up yes you're
in New York obviously and you're playing
a show tonight it's sold out very
ballroom well this is my second ever
show and it's my second ever sellout so
it's pretty fun to like get to do that
and I've only opened up for people in
the back so this is like we did we
booked for shows just to kind of test
like dip our toe in like the club tour
headlining and all of them have sold out
so far so we're about to announce some
more dates and right that was probably
the biggest question we got like people
want to know when they can see you we're
gonna announce some more in the next two
weeks so yeah but like all those places
like when you when you announce a tour
or shows everybody like nobody's like
yeah this is awesome they're like
brazilians they're so thrilled because
yeah yeah they really are big country
music fan base um so you've actually
written a lot in addition to being a
solo performer you've written a lot of
songs for other artists do you prefer to
sing your own songs or write songs for
other people what's easier what makes
more money writing songs for other
people 100% makes more noise I mean it's
so interesting but like the idea is that
that's probably not what I love doing
both things right and I came up as a
writer I never really imagined doing the
like having my own project and it's been
cooled in the last like year to kind of
feel that start to snowball in the same
way that my write like my writing is
just that's what got me here to
Nashville in country music and the
touring stuff is just starting to pick
up and the radio stuff on my artists
side is starting to pick up so I love I
love doing both things that I talk about
like what I do is like wearing two shoes
like there's a left and a right and I
kind of need both of them because when
you're a writer you get to be creative
every single day and when you're an
artist it's a lot of just like different
things that aren't really related to
music like you have to be good at
Instagram which is like
we teach you yeah you can you can
consult yes nice we do have like a five
inch taller now Rafi but I'll wait
because you're a friend of the chess
that's pretty reasonable yeah I think so
too yeah you can't put a price on yeah
you have to be at like radio things all
the time and like there's just a lot of
things that go into it that are not
musical so when writing it's all
creative so it's nice to have like both
outlets yeah so who's someone that you
haven't worked with yet or wrote for it
but that you want to I've written for a
lot of people in Nashville so like it
Florida Georgia line and extent Luke
Bryan Lady Antebellum like the J :
I've had a lot of in Marin - I've had a
lot of success in Nashville I've never
really had much success outside of
Nashville so but I've never really tried
to do that so I would love like we're
gonna start doing a little more like LA
writing and stuff like that just to like
get some different sounds and and just
because now that we have been doing it
for a while those doors have opened up
so I would love to start doing just a
little bit more like la side what songs
have you written with slash for Marin I
wrote a couple on this new one oh you
did okay what's a vibe can you suggest
her album yeah it's like it's better
than the last one I don't know that I'm
really gonna be good but you know I'm
here to pipe it up because I want to go
on vacation it's great um and I wrote a
couple on there which is really fun
that's not the most important thing
anymore to like but it is really special
when we get to be creative yeah I wrote
I wish I was on the first album and
we've written songs for other people too
so um and then she's written a handful
on mine and like obviously sings
background on stuff that she decides she
wants to sing on so it's fun when that
gets to happen but yeah I can't give too
much I mean girl is the first taste of
album and it's like that's a pretty good
indicator of what it's gonna like what
the direction is cool so what's like a
banger that you have written that we
might not know like a country banger um
well I wrote you look good for Lady
Antebellum
and that was a top five hit and that we
do that in our show too so I do like my
own version of that and that's that's
pretty fun to like have it's it's like a
song with horns and
like a really cool baseline and so yeah
that's kind of fun to like surprise
people with that and show like what what
like kind of the original version of
what surprising people
and speaking of songs are you saying at
your shows um the cover of you doing
Taylor Swift stress went viral and I
like loved it can you talk about why you
chose that song and just like why I
loved it and I just want to know why
because I feel like people are never
gave me Taylor the respect she deserves
well we met tailored this last fall on
the reputation stadium tour and she was
kind enough to have Marian come sing the
middle and like I hung out with Taylor
she's so cool and she is amazing like me
and Andrea just like walked around the
whole stadium together and like whatever
but I it was actually planning on
cutting on doing that song live before
that because first of all it's really
brilliantly written song and I thought
it'd be really cool it was my favorite
song off that album and I thought it was
be it would be really cool from like a
male voice mm-hmm
to like seeing the opposite like
Prospectus but with the exist no I keep
the pronouns pretty intact you do I
change one one word I just add a you in
front of the hook and it really works
but I thought it was a brilliantly
written song and that's I just wanted
something a little left of center I
don't really do covers I've never done
covers in my set just because I wanted
to like establish when I was opening for
other people I just wanted to establish
myself kind of as my own artist and but
we do two covers in this that we do
anything of mine which is a Kenny
Chesney song from like 12 years ago
that's like one of my favorite country
songs of all time so it's still a very
country music set but adding the Taylor
song I didn't really expect it to I mean
you write it a bunch of people there's a
lot of people who love Taylor Swift but
people really love that so I'll take it
but so when you do something like that
at is where Genie provision like to sing
something live do you want me to go over
licensed things yeah okay uh basically
when you record a song
you're giving a first use license so
you're not allowed to record a written
song until the writers and maybe like
with Taylor she is the writer so this is
like a formality that doesn't have to
happen but you have to have a license to
record the song first and once the song
has been recorded for the first time and
released commercially then anyone can
technically record it and then the
royalties from the use go sing but
playing it live I mean technically
Taylor would receive royalties for me
playing it live because it would be
turned in whatever because all of those
clubs have to pay a license fee to play
music so to have live music but I don't
think she's getting rich off me playing
it she's gonna come collect and you
watch she might and now I will gladly
write the check we got some really
interesting questions for you and
pulling from Instagram what are you
binging on Netflix right now on Netflix
narcos I watched narcos Mexico and I was
so emotionally like into it that I went
and rewatched all the original narcos
there's like three seasons of that I'm
like halfway through season one again so
don't know it's really powerful stuff I
think like right now it's really
powerful too because we're talking about
walls and we're talking about other
stuff and you're like the human cost of
the drug stuff is wild but like so crazy
that job but the show is emotionally it
really isn't incredible so I love that's
what I'm in right now do you have any
plans in New York this weekend are you
gonna see Kacey Musgraves she's here at
the Beacon Theatre this weekend you know
what we are playing the same night oh
yeah she slinks out her a joke and she's
playing Saturday also our friend Kate
and our friends Kate and Lisa are
singing background vocals with her for a
couple nights but we're leaving we're
supposed to leave before it's pretty
Hayley kudlick who's like whatever if
someone was a huge fan if someone was
gonna listen to one of your songs which
one would you want them to hear I think
Michigan for the winner is like the song
that I just released that's the most
indicative of what I do as a writer and
it's the response has been huge so far
but I never thought that a song like
that which is super songwriter II would
have the response
that it did so I think if you were gonna
listen to one thing and be like that's
what this dude's all about it would be
that song also to a tee cuz it's going
to the radio and I'd really like for it
to be super successful okay
okay we can make that happen you guys to
tee them Sam Smith who do you think is
putting out some of the best music right
now obviously besides Mary because that
wouldn't be fair
Maggie Rogers oh we agree do you watch
her on SNL what do you think of her
dancers I would like I think she's
brilliant I just it's a cool record and
party in Nashville if you guys have ever
liked it that's that dude is he wrote a
song called science over you and it's a
song about he wrote a story about coming
home after going to the bar and writing
himself a note on the refrigerator
saying don't call her and the hook is
like signed sober you and it's a
brilliantly written song and that's the
one that I kind of have been gravitating
towards lately but yeah I mean Nashville
there's so much stuff in Nashville that
people like who aren't necessarily fans
of country music don't don't always hear
but I think we have like the best
songwriters in the world there so but
there's always cool stuff you ever watch
a show Nashville question yes thoughts
Nashville the show was really fun
because like it was filmed and like all
these real places except for the
Bluebird shows we're all feeling in a
studio like this but I was I don't know
I became like a Rayna James super fan
destructive yeah it really was
Margo wasn't okay she didn't watch for
like two years it was fun to tweet about
Rayna in all caps but I mean the there
are a lot of parts that aren't
necessarily true but that's not that
important it was fun show and it did a
lot of people like it was a huge moment
yes Lenin Lenin especially now she's
yeah she's incredible
yeah we were just we're kind of doing
like the same tour right now like we're
sort of following each other around of
these remain but she's got a big to a
plan I think and um yeah Maren loves
Lana Lenin so it's pretty cool and she
final questions for you one is something
that you said on Instagram a couple
years ago that was kind of controversial
but incredibly true
just complaining about the bachelor be
in two hours that was that controversial
no the last two hours to watch this show
nobody and then one hour to debrief and
talk about it yeah
the next morning every week is out of
control do you watched as Marin watch
religiously does she make you watch with
her we I've been in and out I have more
of a bachelorette fan and I always kind
of have been because I think that the
dudes take it a lot less seriously than
the girls do and I I just imagine what I
would be doing if I was the bachelor
like first thing I would do hands down I
would sit everybody walks in you say hi
anyone who comes in with a gimmick is
automatically rewarded so you're
speaking a rock in the wrong accent or
you wear a mask or a bag or whatever you
put on your head like that to me
automatic pass also I lay it down
immediately I see if you try to steal
someone away from me then you're out
okay we're done but they're not
entertaining any of this because that
and also I would like to say you're the
third rule is you're playing a game this
is a game and if we happen to become
something more later than that is fine
but this is a game and I think that
would make the show more way more
entertaining because right now it's so
predictable yeah it's like hey can I
steal you and then like the guy always
says yes what why they should say no
sometimes yeah just when it's unsafe
yeah I'd be like you're not gonna get a
rose anyways I'm not gonna spend any
more time with you I just I don't think
it needs to be two hours and I honestly
just forgot that it was two hours
because we were watching and I was like
okay this is over and it felt like it
was over and then they came back and I
think wait this is I forgot this is two
hours I'm gonna two hours long every
show it's a movie only like an hour of
content and it's an hour of commercials
it's a movie yeah it really it is you
get so much done and that's why do you
think they're gonna see this and change
their ways well honestly that's show you
described it to to bed that you're
married cuz I would watch out like
hardcore
I yeah I have no I'm so glad that I am
married so not that I would ever have
the opportunity to do that or ever have
like the emotional capacity for it but
these are just ways that I think I can
improve the world you kind of look like
a guy who would be
it's true like Nashville's yeah hope
brings his guitar like I would not in
any way be able to take any of it
seriously so I would either be the
greatest or the greatest failure because
I would just be like this is a complete
joke it is a no sorry sorry pain he's
doing a good job you're not a joke I
just find the show to be taken too
seriously did you see that he's in the
studio now singing honestly the songs
not so bad like the song hasn't come out
yet it was just a teaser it didn't sound
so maybe he's a great singer
you never know some people hidden
talents maybe he's great I don't know
like that's that's the fun part about
music is like you all it takes is one
song do you guys see any of them around
town any of the bachelor contestants at
events things like that
I think Maron met the girl that everyone
said looked like her Jojo oh they did
used to look like women I can't say I
think they maybe met one time and
blocked on Twitter or something like I
could be wrong about that but I know
that they maybe conversed I think I saw
I don't think I've seen she no like
she'll text me sometimes and be like
Ari's in the restaurant but yeah I think
that was LA in New York but I like that
she'll she'll hit like under the table
text me like somebody's like cool my
family question before I let you go I
was kind of big deal and it's like a
little bit of a curveball so just wait
for it your hair yeah you made the
decision to cut it sure explain the
decision and do you think you'd go back
too long do you think it helps like are
you Samson like it's your strength your
songwriting capabilities living your
hair okay
I love having long hair I've had it for
most of my adult life and my manager and
my wife each told me they each told me
it's time so it was time but then Marin
said I'm nicer when I have long hair so
I'm trying to grow it back out but it's
kind of hard because we're taking so
many photos right now because we're out
here doing right so maybe that's why I'm
wearing a hat today but trying to we're
like right in between having to like
figure out if we're gonna keep it going
or stop so uh I don't know
would love to have it back though I I
just I I think it makes you look
different and I haven't always enjoyed
it and but I like short hair too like
it's it's it's fun it's honestly a
little easier to keep up with the short
hair that you got to cut it if you
wanted to grow right I've been cutting
it every three weeks what about a bowl
cut bring it back you know that would be
a statement you're just the guy to bring
it back I'm just the guy all right so it
could yeah I don't think I could do that
I think you could but when we're like I
wanted to have longer hair for touring
because it's always cooler in photos
when it's all sweaty in your face to me
it seems cooler maybe nobody else agrees
well you'll be going to the Grammys
correct
I yeah walking the red carpet with a
ball cut I think you could do it maybe a
mullet oh yeah it's funny because you do
all this work to like be in these on
these carpets in these shows and I'm
literally just like a side piece but
sometimes I get in like these cool
little like best-dressed lists I don't
think I've been in any worst dressed
list yeah but I'm sure it's common but
if I had the bowl cut I'm unstoppable
the press alone press alone is worth the
cut I agree that okay so if you're gonna
see the shows tonight is sold out sorry
you guys can't get tickets sorry but
Kenneth Ryan on instagram for all the
shows is gonna announce in 2019 we're
definitely gonna go to one and that's
all we got for you it's Friday so have a
great weekend we'll see you on Monday
you